today i'll talk about diet and gut  microbiome  our gut microbiome is estimated 39  trillion microbial cells that means we  have more bacterial cells in our body  than our own cells  and this microbiome is consist of two  type of bacteria some are helpful and  some are harmful  and their relative composition is  actually induced by what we eat so our  diet can influence the gut microbiome  composition for example if we eat food  which are enriched in protein and fat  that induces  the proliferation of harmful bacteria  and that can cause many metabolic  disease in contrast if we eat fruits  vegetables and lots of fiber rich food  then it would promote metabolic health  and triggers good bacteria so overall  our gut microbiome is highly dependent  on the food that we eat that's one  minute see you in next video